[Musica]
negli ultimi 20 anni il mondo in cui
viviamo e cambia
finalmente sono cambiati televisori
siamo passati dagli schermi a tubo
catodico agli schermi ultrapiatti sono
cambiati anche i telefoni siamo passati
dalle cabine telefoniche agli smartphone
che tutti avete in tasca in questo
momento anche la moneta che utilizziamo
è cambiata quando io ero bambina cioè
non ho le lire aiuti a voi euro
c'è una cosa però che non è cambiata non
sono cambiate le nostre scuole
le nostre aule sono uguali a quelle di
vent'anni fa
anzi a dire il vero e sono quali anche a
quelle di cento anni fa certo abbiamo
sostituito le lavagne con il gesto con
le lavagne interattive inviamo mail
invece di scrivere sul diario e i voti
di scriviamo sul tablet però gli
studenti stanno ancora dietro gli stessi
banchi ai professori stanno ancora
dietro le stesse cattedre
se il compito della scuola è quello di
formare i cittadini e lavoratori del
futuro ancora senza insegnare come
facevamo prima
non facciamo 20 anzi cento anni fa
io penso di no per questo ho deciso di
fare qualcosa di concreto di mettermi
l'impegno in questa cosa e tra l'altro
non è stata una scelta per niente facile
da pro la studentessa mi ero laureata
con il massimo dei voti al politecnico
qui a torino col subito cominciato a
lavorare in un'azienda di tecnologia un
bel lavoro un bell'ufficio dei colleghi
simpatici
il problema però è che mi sembrava di
non sta facendo niente di concreto per
rendere questo mondo un posto migliore
così ho deciso di licenziarmi se penso
alla faccia che hanno fatto i miei
quando ho detto loro che volevo
licenziarmi da un contratto a tempo
indeterminato per andare a lavorare con
i ragazzini mi viene ancora un po male
comunque adesso il mio lavoro e lavorare
tra i ragazzini e quando dico tra i
ragazzini intendo proprio fisicamente
tra i ragazzini
sulla carta se proprio male al massimo
mi chiedo però in generale nelle aule in
questo io la cattedra non c'è il mio
lavoro è insegnare ai ragazzini a
costruire e programmare robot o un
vantaggio certo non sono una prof
e soprattutto o i robot i ragazzini che
hanno 12 15 anni partono da zero zero
competenze di informatica a 0 competenze
ingegneristiche
eppure imparano e imparare in fretta
l'approccio e dare loro un obiettivo da
raggiungere e lasciare che ci si
spacchino la testa sopra finché non ci
arrivano
non sono abbandonati a loro stessi
possono farmi tutte le domande che
vogliono se proprio non so rispondere a
qualcosa
e capita spesso cerchiamo insieme la
risposta giusta su internet
il punto però è che ci devono arrivare
da soli possono sbagliare tutte le volte
che vogliono il bello di questo
approccio è questo che l'errore non è un
problema anzi l'errore fa parte del
processo di apprendimento possono
sbagliare e riprovare quello che ne
facciamo in fondo e imparare a risolvere
problemi
il robot è solo una scusa per avvicinare
i ragazzi a quello che si chiama
pensiero computazionale pensiero
computazionale non è una parolaccia
pensiero computazionale vuol dire sapere
individuare un processo fatto di tanti
piccoli passaggi semplici e chiari che
portano alla risoluzione di un problema
complesso per farvi un esempio è un
esercizio di pensiero computazionale
anche montare un mobile che ha o seguire
una ricetta di cucina
comunque i ragazzi ci arrivano per
tentativi per prove ed errori sbagliano
un sacco di volte all'inizio fanno così
a caso poi cominciano a capire cosa
stanno facendo
dopo un po hanno abbastanza chiaro il
processo che seguono alla fine
perfezionano anche i passaggi
comunque alla fine ci arrivano sempre ve
lo assicuro anzi la maggior parte delle
volte mi sorprendono quando pensa un
obiettivo da dare loro penso anche a
quanto tempo potrebbero metterci di
solito un'ora
magari anche un'ora e mezza capita
spesso però che dopo una quarantina di
minuti arrivino con un sorriso non
averci all'altro ben livelli tutti
allegri mi dicono viviana viene a vedere
ce l'abbiamo fatta
devo ammettere che comunque sono
soddisfazioni
sapendo poi che il mondo del lavoro è
cambiato che insomma adesso tutte le tv
le offerte di lavoro sul mercato
richiedono il problem solving la
proattività il lavoro di gruppo e
compagnia bella
come faccio a non pensare che questi
ragazzi andranno fortissimo il mondo del
lavoro di fatto è cambiato e cambiato
tanto sono cambiati mestieri sono
cambiate le competenze richieste è
cambiato anche il modo di lavorare
la scuola seppur lentamente sta cercando
di adattarsi a questi cambiamenti
insomma non siamo gli unici che ci
stanno lavorando sopra cominciano ad
apparire delle aule digitali cominciano
ad apparire banchi con forme diverse
cominciano apparire anche le connessioni
internet veloci e percorsi di studio in
cui
informatica ha un ruolo importante in
alcune scuole i banchi sono disposti in
cerchio e le cattedre sono sparite in
alcune aule i ragazzi possono usare
liberamente il tablet durante le lezioni
di fatto però stiamo ancora cercando di
capire come far convivere la vecchia
scuola con la nuova scuola e ci vorrà
ancora un po di tempo prima che questa
convivenza diventi civile consideriamo
anche il fatto che la nostra classe
docente non è proprio giovanissima e
quindi qualche difficoltà interfacciarsi
con la tecnologia e in generale con i
nativi digitali ancora ce l'ha comunque
il processo è partito alla fine ce la
faremo
questa è una delle mie classi con come
vedete c'è una folla di ragazzine e lo
so non tantissime
il compito della scuola sarebbe quello
di dare a tutti la possibilità di essere
preparati al futuro in pratica non basta
più insegnare loro le tabelline le
poesie dobbiamo fare in modo che tutti
siano preparati al futuro però tutti
come potete vedere non è un concetto
scontato in questo settore
voglio raccontarvi una storia e successo
in una delle mie classi abbiamo provato
a fare un esperimento abbiamo raccontato
i ragazzi che cos'è il gender gap e
abbiamo spiegato loro che le ragazze si
scrivono poco alle facoltà scientifiche
e che anzi nel mondo del lavoro
il settore scientifico e tecnologico e
poco popolato di donne questo è un dato
reale
le donne sono poche davvero nel settore
scientifico
secondo i dati istat solo il 30 per
cento degli iscritti alle facoltà del
gruppo scientifico e donna
se si va a vedere l'area dell'ingegneria
la percentuale cala ancora fino al 22
per cento
se poi guardiamo la mia esperienza mi è
capitato di dare esami al politecnico in
cui ero l'unica donna in aula il
problema ce l'abbiamo
comunque tornando all'esperimento con i
ragazzi abbiamo detto loro questa cosa a
parte le facce stupite perplesse di
tutti come se stessimo raccontando loro
un sacco di stupidaggini
c'è subito la risposta che ci ha dato
uno di loro matteo matteo ci ha detto
con tutta le 900 del mondo testuali
parole
vabbè saranno anche poche ma di sicuro
sono le migliori
voglio credere che se ce la fa matteo
che ha 13 anni a dare fiducia alle donne
forse ce la possiamo fare tutti
insomma che c'è speranza ancora una cosa
un consiglio spassionato
guardate che robot leggo in puzzle si
possono regalare anche alle bambine
anzi fatemi un favore più leggo e meno
barbie non perché ce l'abbia con le
bambole sia chiaro però se diamo un'idea
di parità a queste bambine quando hanno
cinque anni non scarteranno più or il
corso di robotica quando avranno 12 anni
una facoltà scientifica quando ne
avranno 18 è un lavoro nel settore della
tecnologia quando avranno la mia età
[Applauso]